all right the audience questions have
been getting better and better the last
several months and we've got some really
good ones here Tyler wrote in saying hey
guys people often overestimate how
dangerous certain things are like for
example commercial aviation what do
people drastically underestimate the
danger of this is a good question I mean
just for a second to stick with the
aviation example although commercial
aviation in the United States is
incredibly safe I do think that some
people believe that piloting small
single-engine propeller planes is
basically just as safe as commercial
aviation and that's not so I think that
there are people that overestimate the
safety of commercial of a non-commercial
small plane piloting but I think just
driving in the car every day is
something that you can't think of the
reality that statistically getting into
a car is orders of magnitude more
dangerous than getting on a commercial
American Airline plane and if you did it
would almost be crippling because in
most of the country you get into cars
constantly without thinking it is far
more dangerous than the average person
is sort of cognizant of every time they
get into a car probably because you do
it just about every day so it's part of
the routine you're completely
desensitized to it whereas if you're
going to be taking a flight somewhere if
you're going to do something like
adventurous skydiving then there's all
this build-up to it you think your time
to think about what could possibly go
wrong
I think that's a good point and I think
that some similar applies to the ocean
where I mean I'm not I want to be clear
I don't want to irrationally overstate
the danger of some of these things but
getting into the ocean assuming listen
if there is a Riptide I'll easily be
able to swim out of it most people
actually don't know how to swim get get
out of the danger caused by a Riptide I
don't know that I do and I'm an okay
swimmer I think on a day-to-day basis
from a statistical point of view most
people drastically underestimate the the
violence with which the ocean could take
you in
how about carnival rides I know there
was that eighteen year old kid who died
a few weeks ago at the Ohio State Fair
due to corrosion on one of the rides and
you know maybe at an amusement park
those things in math
aren't too too dangerous but given the
fact that these carnivals are going from
town to town and have to be set up and
torn down over and over again and many
times they're old I'd imagine that's
pretty dangerous yeah I think so too and
also you know there's been a lot we
talked a lot about how homeopathy is
medically bogus but there is an aspect
of so-called natural supplements and
medications that is dangerous because
some just because something is quote
all-natural and contains sort of
unregulated products in the sense that
they don't need to be regulated because
they're herbs or plants or whatever the
case may be that also is part of the
danger and you can have interactions
between so-called all-natural products
and medications that are prescribed to
you that can be very very dangerous and
I think a lot of people don't don't
think about that I know a lot of people
who say when I have X symptoms and
sometimes it's allergy sometimes it's
cold sometimes it's sleeplessness
they'll buy a cocktail of
over-the-counter stuff assuming like
listen if any of this was really that
strong it would require a prescription
that may be true but in large doses or
in combination with other things a lot
of that stuff can be quite dangerous yes
especially if it's in combination with
say alcohol too because of course you
know there's gonna be warnings about not
drinking while you're on the drug but
yeah some people just think that that's
over an overall health concern people
ignore that nor that yeah oh one other
one because we mentioned the ocean
saving someone from drowning is
incredibly dangerous it is very common
that if you really don't know how to
save someone who's drowning you end up
being drowned or at risk of drowning
yourself really and a lot of people
don't know that because someone who is
drowning is going to basically be using
the person trying to save that to get
above water and the way you do that is
by pulling them under and if you're not
properly trained at saving someone from
drowning you you could die
potentially and everything goes to do
wait till they pass out I honestly I
don't know what the right thing is to do
like if you see someone drowning and
you're not properly trained most people
would have trouble just ignoring that
you mobile you would feel compelled to
do something anyway those are a few
ideas great question
Tyler like that one